james harrison is a two-time super bowl
winner and he's kind enough to call in
right here on the rich eisen show on
this christmas eve on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line how are you james
i'm doing good man how you doing i'm
doing fine so um where do you think the
pittsburgh steelers season is right now
based on what you've seen and maybe what
you might even uh know what do you think
of it so far well
um
i think that they're doing a lot with
what they have um i believe that the
defense you know um despite the lapses
that they had and run gang things you
know here and there
is going to be what's going to carry
this team and if the offense can just
you know put up you know enough points
hold the ball long enough to to give
them guys a rest i think they have a
chance to to make it into the playoffs
how far they'll go
i don't want to um put any type of uh
number on that because you know it's
it's a talented team but it's not as
talented as stuff
so where would you put do you would you
put tj watt in the uh
uh would you give him defensive player
of the war year award i mean he's in and
out of the lineup but he's still
producing insane numbers you got miles
garrett in the in that conversation
micah parsons
for dallas yeah you you got you got you
got you know quite a few guys in that
conversation he's definitely in the
conversation um you know i think the
only thing that would you know probably
hinder data system guys you know um
don't don't make the playoffs and you
know he's able to continue to actually
be healthy and be you know in there to
where he just throws up astronomical
numbers and it's just too hard to not
give it to him
so what do you think of micah parsons
what do you think of that kid on dallas
james um he's doing you know he's doing
good um
you know it's uh
it's it's one year uh
you know and i think you know once you
know they get a a good year they belt
and they realize what type of talent he
is i think they'll start to try and
adjust to it and then we'll see
you know next year exactly you know
exactly where he'll be heading after
they make those adjustments oh so the
rubber is yet to meet the road for him
or with him in your estimation that's
what you're saying james for me yeah i
would say that you don't see like
something i don't know he's just jumping
off the screen to me i mean he's also
that's no question about it i mean you
have you have guys that that come in and
blow things out in that that first year
and then the next year
um you know whether it's uh
the
teams or or coaches uh doing things
different than next year or maybe you
know you have that that sophomore slump
you know
so
um i mean you know we're we're going to
see but he's definitely
like i said he's in that conversation
too for
defensive players you're rookie you'll
get it all
yeah i know rod woodson once told me the
greatest uh adapting organism in the nfl
is an nfl defense i'm just wondering if
offenses and blocking schemes and stuff
like that might actually be the same
thing but not even blocking me they're
just gonna have to put more guys
dedicate more guys to him
what's the most you ever had somebody
dedicate guys to you back in the day
james um
i think what you mean like the most
number of guys
yeah one where you're like how many are
they going to send my way like what i
i've had i've had i've had three that's
the most i've had three
yeah okay so that's what uh tackle
lineman running back
tap on two tackling tackle and uh two
running backs
well running backs for you you probably
had to laugh at that right no
running backs no see because you got to
get past the tackle first and
now they're you know you're still two
guys you shouldn't be able to get
through that okay two on one should be a
win for the two guys at all times well
did you win in the three on one against
you no i did not win i won and a two on
one i did not win in thrill
three on one yeah well did somebody else
win because i guess that would be the
key right if there's somebody three on
one on you then let someone else win in
that regard right it take you know if
you can if you can do that it gives
somebody else a nice one-on-one
somewhere else james harrison here on
the rich eisen show i'm going to take my
shot with this question usually i answer
ask questions i already know or have a
sense of what the answer is so um my our
my buddy adam schefter reported that big
ben's telling people it's his last year
are you one of those people that he told
oh he did not tell me no okay are you in
contact with him at all or no not really
a little bit yeah a little bit what's
your sense then
what do you think
if he said this is last year i'm gonna
have to go with it's just last year what
do you say what do you think when you
see it or just any sense of it do you
think that he is
that this is his last run with the
steelers
right now
well i was kind of surprised that he
actually came back after you know ponzi
had retired and all that so
um you know that was a surprise to me
once he's saying this is his last year
i'm gonna assume that you know that's
that's what he means why were you
surprised by that that he would come
back
that connection there and you know from
conversations that we had in the past it
was a likely hill that when he left he
was leaking
they were that because that that was one
of the more famous
shots of this on the sideline during
last year's playoffs when it was obvious
that pouncey was going to go and the two
of them were in tears on the bench
right yeah i remember that so that's
what you're you're referring to is that
close oh yeah
huh
i guess he didn't want to quit football
you know when it comes down to it
yeah it's hard you know it's hard to
give up something that you've been doing
that long and you have love for so how
would you have handled
how would you have handled um the chase
claypool moment from the other day when
claypool with
less than 40 seconds ago and a clock
ticking
made a first down symbol and 14 more
seconds came off the clock
in a loss how would you have handled
that moment in the locker room james
harris i don't have to answer that and i
don't have to give an opinion because
i'm never going to coach
well you as a team leader is what i'm
saying a team leader would you have
pulled him aside and said something or
just left it up oh yeah you definitely
had to talk to him because the team
comes before you know everything else
especially in a situation like that you
know that gives you know then at least
one more shot if not two more shots at
the end zone after the ball is broken up
you know
so you know that that's something that
you definitely have a conversation with
and
you know it needs to be some type of um
you know
punishment
for that right
james harrison here on the rich eisen
show who's the best team do you think
what's your super bowl prediction in
this crazy mixed up season
with three weeks to go james i don't
know no more everybody losing to people
i don't think they should lose to and
then they beat people i think they
should be right
i
i mean it's it's really up in the air
for me uh you know it could be
i mean i can't count out tampa because
you know they got time you
can't you can't count out the rams
because they got a d
um
and then i'm kind of suspicious on what
kansas city is doing is they're really
coming back like the old kansas city or
they just
just showing a little bit here and there
and they go farther at some point i
don't know
those games pittsburgh kansas city when
you were around there those were awesome
those were intense games i just remember
those games those games were
you got any good memories of any of
those games james from those all good
memories man you know especially um you
know the ones that we want
of course
uh
but um
i mean it's nothing that really you know
truly sticks out okay you know playing
the game and
trying to get to the next next week
right and then you got tb12 doing what
he's doing down in in tampa florida uh
when you went into new england and met
him and saw him firsthand wha what what
uh
what did you
assess when you first saw tom brady as a
teammate up close as opposed to a target
for you to take down after all those
years
uh real good real good dude probably you
know one of the uh
best individual you know teammates that
i can say you know i've had as far as
just his camaraderie and you know
actually genuinely caring about you know
the person and not the player what do
you mean by that
what do you mean like he introduced
himself to everybody as if you don't
know who he is like the practice squad
dude in hey i'm tom brady he's the first
one to introduce himself to
you know um
when it's time to go outside mr 15 below
he's like yeah let's go let's get it
going it's no complaint you know um i've
never seen anybody i've never never seen
anybody study how to tell him that's for
sure
like this dude damn near fills up a
whole like notebook a game
what do you mean like he's got he just
jokes yes notes like you take a little
notebook a 70 like page notebook this
dude damn their feels that up the whole
game
every game
so like let's just say a notebook like
from grade school right like that
yeah something like that 70 page 125
and so he would he would finish up a
game and he'd sit down and he'd just
write notes no leading up to the game
huh
did you ever take a look inside one of
those books
at all no i don't care what the offense
does
okay i just didn't know if you were just
so wow see and he's sitting there and
he's looking through notes and and um
i've never heard that one before i
wonder if i assume he still does it and
listen he is talking about
what the defense did the defensive
coordinator
what he was doing with this other team
that he was with 10 years ago and how
this guy is this person in this defense
from this past defense
and this was leading up to the super
bowl in
minnesota when we were playing philly
right we got a meeting
on monday my seat is right by the front
door he taps me on the shoulder as he's
walking past he say hey get ready he's
about to score a bunch of points
that was almost two weeks before the
super bowl
that's what he said we're about to score
a whole bunch of points okay get ready
we're about to score a bunch of points
how do
how how do you take something like that
you're you're like that probably gets a
bunch of points
no i'm just saying that knows me yeah
that's what i'm saying i mean just like
to for for you to be a veteran at the
game and have tom brady tap you on the
shoulder and say we're about to score a
bunch of people wasn't that the game no
no no no no that's what i'm saying but
you you before he had already did all
his
right
his back work his studying all that
i love it that is incredible i'm
wondering what it makes feels for you to
feel as a defensive player and who've
been put so much time in the game as you
already had to hear someone like brady
say something like that before the super
bowl obviously that's got to give you
some wind at your sales i'd imagine
right
you know that is amazing uh hey james i
appreciate the time always appreciate uh
our conversations uh you be well be
healthy be safe and have a great holiday
season with you and your family
appreciate the time all right now take
it easy you got it that's james harrison
everybody right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here